[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello I'm Xena but are we in a lovely
warm welcome from Santiago Chile for the
first ever BBC World News intelligence
squared debate from South America now we
all know that the use and trade of
illicit drugs is a massive problem for
every country but nearly all of the
global supply of cocaine comes from here
in South America so it is this part of
the world which is on the front line of
the war on drugs and sadly as a result
has the highest murder rate on earth
well now influential voices on the
continent and beyond as saying that the
war on drugs has failed and that it is
time for a new and radical approach so
that is our motion here in Chile the
world should legalize drugs and we have
a great lineup of speakers for the
motion former President of Chile Ricardo
Lagos and also with him is the eminent
economist Klaus Schmidt Havel also from
Chile
arguing against the motion from the
United States
Robert Bonner the former head of the US
Drug Enforcement Agency and also the
renowned Brazilian psychiatrist dr.
Ronaldo Lehren Shera
that is our panel welcome to all so
we're going to hear our four speakers
put their arguments for and against the
motion and then we will invite comments
from the floor from the audience here in
Santiago and we will ask the audience to
vote to see where they stand on the
motion during the course of this debate
all right our first speaker Ricardo
Lagos was president of Chile from 2000
to 2006 and he left office with an
historic 70 percent approval rating a
distinguished lawyer and human rights
activist he was foremost amongst the
opponents of General Augusto Pinochet
and he also served on the global
Commission on drugs policy
let me begin saying with a very clear
statement all of us agree here that
consumption of drugs is harmful for
health for human beings after saying
that I will say that the 1961 United
Nations Single Convention on narcotic
drugs is correct when in a very clear
way they say in the convention that the
final purpose of the system was to
improve the health and welfare of
mankind that's the real issue I could
say that the decision was to say sin
drugs are bad market of drugs is going
to be illicit illegal and that's in
period and we have to punish the
production the cultivation distribution
everything to some extent and we have to
punish in a very strong way as it should
be
this punative
law enforcement paradigm I think that is
over that in 1960 nobody could envision
what's going to happen in today's world
because in today's world after 50 year
consumption has increased at incredible
levels so from this point of view it's a
benefit
needless to say the production in
dollars terms is huge in everything in
cocaine 85 billions
heroine 55 billions cannabis 141 billion
and so on so
and this is the reason why I think that
the paradigm is failing is a big
business that is produced mostly in this
part of the world but most of the
consumption take place in the other part
of the world in the developed part of
the world and I don't need to tell you
that both of the increases in this part
of the world are rather small we
serviced the large increase that take
place in the developed world
nevertheless is in this part of the
world where most of the fighting the
gunfight the narco traffic is taking
place and is producing what we can see
every day in short I think that now the
time has come to have a different
paradigm where you are going to be able
to use and to say look first is a
question of health we forget to those
that are addicted and has no way to
solve the issue it's much easier to
provide them the drug by official
channels
number two is essential to understand
that the only way is to be able to focus
from the part of the money supply there
has been many ways this question of
weapons and controls all of us know that
the weapons of those people are very
passive with the weapons of many of the
armies in this region number three
militaries a crackdown may exacerbate
criminal violence and the big issue is
are we going to be able to break the
taboo that about that means why is not
going to be able to experiment trying to
legalize trying to sell the Vista same
drugs like a pharmaceutical and let me
ask and let me end with just one
question I don't want to I don't want to
quote Milton Friedman but Milton
Friedman is right
got into Friedman much more people died
because tobacco or alcohol than with
drugs why we have this quite different
way to approach these two issues why
it's not possible to say I'm going to
regulate if it is possible to have that
with regard to drugs and to take the
right measures and to sell at the right
prices and not at the black market and
therefore the gangs the narco traffic
will be defeated because they have no
money to come from the black market
thank you very much
thank you very much arguing against the
motion we have in the United States
Robert Bonner and he's a former head of
the US Drug Enforcement Administration
he's also a former chief of US Customs
and Border Protection and Robert you
also served as a federal judge in
California so please you've done
everything surprise you found the time
to join us today
I'm delighted to be here in Santiago but
let us understand clearly what this
motion is it is a proposal not just to
legalize the use of drugs but to
legalize the manufacture the production
and sale of all drugs that it's that's
not just marijuana ladies and gentlemen
that includes cocaine in both smokeable
crack form and powder it includes heroin
crystal meth amphetamine PCP LSD and
other highly addictive and psychoactive
drugs if you vote for the motion that is
what you will be voting for there is a
vast difference between
decriminalization of the use of drugs
and legalization that is to say
legalizing the large-scale manufacture
and sale of those drugs the first and
foremost reason to above oppose
legalization as proposed both for your
country and around the world is that it
will lead to an increase a substantial
increase in the number of people that
are using and become addicted and become
dependent upon these drugs it only
stands to reason that if addictive drugs
like crack and meth are more readily
available and inexpensive more people in
society especially young people will use
them one must ask do we do you want a
nation of stoners crackheads and junkies
mixed reaction out there I mean the
question is do you want a country where
there's a much larger percentage of
people that are using and abusing and
addicted to drugs like cocaine heroin
and meth I say I hope not
legalization will also result in
commercialization of these drugs we're
already seeing this commercialization of
marijuana in the state of Colorado and
the marijuana industry there is becoming
already powerful and influential it is
not only advertising on Billboard's
around that state but it is packaging
marijuana as candy cookies chocolates
laced with high potency THC which is I
think you know is the psychoactive
ingredient chemical in marijuana and it
will result in a cocaine industry it
will result in a meth industry
methamphetamines and so forth with the
intent of getting more people especially
young people hooked on their product
their influence on politicians with
legalization will be enormous and once
this course is set and this I want you
to remember once the course is set it is
going to be very very difficult ever to
go back president Lagos stipulated that
these drugs are harmful and they are
they are highly addictive and either
psychologically or physically or both
the facts are that one out of three
heroin users becomes addicted to heroin
one out of four cocaine users becomes
addicted and one out of six teenagers
who regularly use marijuana become a
tenth dependent upon it one out of six
lastly the very issue here is why are we
considering this breathtaking radical
proposal of full legalization of all
drugs it's because as has been suggested
the drug war has somehow failed well
we've never had a war on drugs and
certainly in the literal sense of that
term and it's not even a very good
metaphor
for a drug control policy because it
implies some ultimate victory then let
me just say that might that's the goal
of a sound drug policy policy to reduce
the numbers of users of these drugs in
our society and that goal is not aided
by legalization of the production and
sale of these drugs but quite the
opposite it will only make matters worse
thank you
[Music]
Robert Bonner thank you very much so
arguing for the motion now we have from
here in Chile a Klaus Schmidt Hebel he
is professor of economics at the
Catholic University in Chile he is a
former chief economist at the OECD at
his headquarters in Paris and also
smirked as a consultant at the World
Bank and also for many other
institutions and many governments all
over the world so please do come and
make your arguments for the motion let
me start with the obvious drug addiction
or excessive consumption of drugs
meaning wine or cocaine tobacco or
heroine is terrible drug addiction
destroys individuals and destroys entire
families now let me add something less
obvious but equally true the way we have
tried to limit drug addiction and
consumption by declaring most drugs
illegal has failed miserably since the
start of the war on drugs 50 years ago
drug addiction has increased many fold
as exemplified by president Lagos the
lessons of the US prohibition and the
subsequent repeal are most relevant for
the world at large today why because
since the 60s the world is conducting a
police experiment that is similar to the
u.s. prohibition and this is contacted
at a grander global scale it's a
worldwide war on drugs symbolic or not
it's an excellent description of what
the world is up tempting to do but today
the evidence is overwhelming and clear
the world's battlefields in this global
conflict are scattered with the Habra's
the wounded and the dead of this war let
me briefly refer to seven facts that
substantiate why and how we have lost
this 50 year long war on drugs fact
number one ever rising government
resources are spent on enforcing current
drug policies one case the US alone
federal expenditure and drug control
rose from
five billion thirty years ago 225
billion in today's federal budget fact
number two markets of illegal drugs have
grown many folds since the 60s
consumption of soft and hard drugs F has
increased many times in most countries
in the world let's go to prices in the
US the average price of heroine cocaine
and cannabis has declined by at least
eighty percent you in the last two
decades [ __ ] number three the legality
of drugs leads to crime at a massive
scale well beyond drugs
massive illegal production and trade in
drugs leads to large-scale drug mafias
drug wars and spreading of violence and
crime well beyond the direct rate of
illegal drugs a case in point is Mexico
actually since 2008 v seventy five
thousand people seventy five thousand
estimated victims have been killed in
the wars between drug gangs [ __ ] number
four drug addiction has increased many
fold over the last decades here a case
in point is in this country Chile our
country has the world's highest
consumption rate of cocaine crack and
cocaine paste among young people in 2010
mr. bonner we are there this country has
a eight percent rate of life prevalence
under total illegalities and the total
prohibition fact number five new
synthetic drugs come to the markets
every year the last report by the UN
shows that last year 348 new psychedelic
drugs hit world markets taking a growing
share of the total illegal drug market
fact number six wide scale corruption is
spread by draging legality maybe not in
the US but in countries with weaker
institutions like most developing
countries in Asia in Africa in Latin
America are particularly prone to be
corrupted by illegal drug gangs my last
fact number seven the word has legalized
very damaging in drugs something like
eighteen while it is prohibiting others
recent medical studies which to my
knowledge has not
questions to date classifies alcohol
alcohol as a first fourth worst truck in
the world in tobacco as the sixth number
six were struck among 20 drugs all of
the drugs the 18 illegal drugs are
classified according to their damage
ranging from heroine and cocaine very
damaging the first three four places to
LSD steroids and ecstasy's among the
least damaging illegal drugs classified
maybe 15 18 or 19 therefore if we want
to repress consistently and according to
damage to consumers to people we should
criminalize and persecute and prosecute
alcohol and tobacco production alcohol
and tobacco trade and consumption now
however apparently this does not seem to
be a very sensible policy option
therefore as a result of declaring
defeat and the worldwide war on drugs
based on my seven facts what is required
the world requires urgently an
internationally coordinated gradual
legalization of many drugs mr. bonner
not all drugs definitely not all drugs
of many drugs complemented by very
effective prevention and rehab of drug
consumption and addiction thank you very
much
thank you very much indeed Klaus Schmidt
Havel now arguing against the motion the
world should legalize drugs we have from
Brazil
Ronaldo ladder and Shera and he heads
Brazil's national institution for drugs
policy and Ronaldo has written
extensively on the impact of addiction
on for drugs and alcohol both for the
individual and society at large doctor
Lehren Jarrett please your time starts
now
thank you very much as English is not my
first language I do apologize begin my
first point is legalization does not
work before the creation of the tobacco
industry is actually one century ago the
number of tobacco users was around one
percent the biggest event in public
health in the center a twenty century
was the creation of cigarette industrial
cigarettes this product has changed
dramatically this history of public
health tobacco who kill more people in
the last century and all wars in the
last two thousand years that's the size
of them of the damage that the tobacco
industry and that the legalization what
this product means if we knew there what
we know know now about the tobacco would
never legally legalized tobacco but
words be more in Colorado when you
legalize is not legalized only the
joints of cannabis you legalize all sort
of products the industry the cannabis
industry in America today is working the
same line that the tobacco industry 100
years ago and make no mistake when the
one industry launched they stopped a few
weeks ago that they would launch a new
product an electronic cigarette where we
would have a hundred percent of THC I
don't think the legalization will sort
this problem that's not the society that
wants us to imagine that you can have a
catalogue of a different products of
cane cannabis different concentration
and then you can simply buy it I don't
believe it that's possible last example
that they give you is example of Brazil
but you change its law in 2006
a new decriminalize completely drugs
everybody nobody can be arrest because
of using drugs what happened the
consumption increase and the government
didn't do their work didn't create the
prevention didn't do any signals change
the law and leave it to the market
Daniel today we have in the siege of Sao
Paulo a good experience of legalization
that I'd like to invite mr. president
and order that the chinos to see is a
shame for us to live in Sao Paulo when
you have literally hundreds of people
buying and use crack on the streets of
Sao Paulo and the municipal police is
around to protect people talk through to
use these drugs that's an experience of
legalization that's not the idea that I
call a responsible drug policy then
before we discuss about change
dramatically
laws in our country we are doing the
basic a treatment system and the
prevention system that is working and we
have evidence base that many many axes
in prevention can work but you have to
do that you have to invest thank you
very much
[Applause]
thank you very much indeed doctor
Ronaldo Lehren Jerris so you've heard
the arguments from our panelists and we
want to hear from you now hear the
audience in Chile Santiago of course the
capital of Chile but before we do let me
give you the results of our pre debate
votes as you all came in we asked you
where you stand on the motion the world
should legalize drugs for the motion 59%
five nine against the motion 22% and
don't know
19 percent so as things stand the
majority the people here in the audience
in Santiago are for the motion with you
mr. president and Klaus Schmidt Hevel
okay so that's how it stands but don't
give up traps you know depends on how
you take it from here
all right can I invite questions and
comments from the audience please keep
them as brief and to the point
yeah yes my question is for dr. Levin
Guerra why are we discussing this at all
all of you have mentioned the damage
done to young people by this and my
question is more of a medical nature
really than a policy nature why on earth
to human beings especially young ones
get addicted what is it that happens
within ourselves what is it that is so
attractive about this whole business why
do we produce drugs at all is there an
answer
thank you the lady there with yep please
stand hello it seems it's a common
opinion that war against drugs has
failed so let's imagine that we really
legalized drugs my question is a little
step before which conditions should a
country have in order to legalize drugs
and don't have a big social disaster
thank you thank you give it to the
yeah if drugs were legalized what drug
dealers or drug cartels would think and
how are they going to be considered in
the legal framework thank you and
there's a lady there it's clear that
making drugs illegal has created
artificially high prices in the market
so if drugs were be to be legal it's
likely that the cost would drop
considerably after if you were to make
drugs illegal what types of policies
would you propose keeping in mind
keeping in mind that taxes increasing
taxes too much would create incentive
for a black market okay one more to the
lady that yeah so Tilly has one of the
highest level of the world in marijuana
consumption in the range of age from 10
to 17 years old because there is no
awareness of the risk involved the
levels of consumption keep increasing
every year at a certain time the
scientific community has no doubt about
the damage marijuana inflicts on the
capacity to learn and it's linked with
psychotic disorders hmm so mr. president
don't you think that legalizing because
in Chile this is the plan only marijuana
would send a very confusing and
misleading from the authorities to the
young people Thank You mr. president
if you could answer that question there
directly are you not sending confusing
messages first of all I would like to
say that we are not trying to legalize
all drugs you know I don't think it's a
sensible policy what I do know is that
the actual war is not working and I'm
sorry that my opponent didn't mention
the question of what's going on with the
tremendous amount of money of the guns
of the narco traffic because this is
very unfair we produce
but mostly they consume in the other
part of the world and therefore needless
to say that most of the money remains in
the other part of the world because the
system of how much are you increasing
the payment why I say this because you
know the people that is being killed are
being killed in this part of the world
you're not answering you're not
answering the latest question it sounds
like you're making a point there to what
we're doing with regard to marijuana and
we forgot to marry one I would say let
us try let us try and after that you can
say what about cocaine but no more than
that but that will take what five years
ten years okay Rob opponent president
Lagos is backing away from that now so I
think you should vote on our side when
you get a chance but but here's the
message you're sending
you're sending a terrible message to all
of the young people of your country
that's a terrible message because not
only have you said society doesn't
disapprove a people trafficking and
dealing and importing crack and cocaine
and methamphetamine yours actually it's
almost a sign that society is approving
these drugs you don't want to do that
believe me you don't want to do that
notice one thing they said nothing about
my argument that the main reason to vote
against this is you're going to have a
substantial increase in drug users and
addicts and people dependent on drugs in
your society and you are and the reason
they can't deny that is it's undeniable
that is you lower the price and
availability these drugs they are going
to be used more in tonight this state
without doors let me say mr. president
no and and Klaus Klaus raised this point
and I want to address it and that was
that prohibition against alcohol in the
United States did not work well first of
all let's let's let's pay attention to
what the facts are briefly alcohol use
dropped by 130 in the United States
during Prohibition okay so the use of
alcohol actually did drop it's hard to
prohibit by the way a drug that's been
around for 5,000 years and part of our
culture and society might we would
learned that but no just the other thing
yeah just on drugs if we could stick to
drugs for prohibition there was
organized crime in the United States dr.
Renard oléron Jerry you want to come in
but also could you answer that question
about why do in particularly young
people become addicted to drugs you know
that you've worked at the sharp end as a
psychiatrist I think there are a culture
of stimulating the use of drugs has been
around for many years we have a popular
culture on there and of course you have
much more availability of drugs than
used to have 20 years ago 30 years ago
but I want you to answer also a question
which conditions should the country must
before legalization I think it's a good
question you're asking for legalization
I thought you're against the motion I am
against of course but if you decide to
legalize you have as a country you have
said are we offering treatment to
everybody who was affected or dependents
are we offering the best evidence-based
prevention that you have are we offering
to the families all the support that
they didn't have because it's important
now for each people using drugs you have
four people effect which are their
families quickly that question was also
talking about the obstacles and I think
it was Klaus who mentioned in his
presentation that you've got countries
with very weak institutions in this part
of the world sadly we know that
President Molina of Guatemala has talked
about how the drug cartels the gangs
have actually infiltrated state
institutions like the judiciary the
security forces is that more the problem
in this part of the world rather than
the drugs on this part of the world and
also in West Africa in West Africa you
have the narco states where the drug
traffickers are taking over several
countries in West Africa and of course
it's not legalization that to solve the
problem of West Africa or even Aden
other countries here in in Latin America
of course you have to have a proper
government you have to invest in
education invest and anti-corruption you
have to not is if you legalize drugs in
West Africa you want to make it one
thing that is really bad even work Navan
bursts one question if drugs were
legalized what would happen what would
happen to the drug cartels that people
who sell drugs your question but it's a
question from the audience from the lady
was what happens to prices and what
happens to quantities and this is a very
important questions will consumption
increase will prices decline or will be
a whether they increase we do not have a
scientific answer for that question we
had the answer from these two gentlemen
here they said studies show that once
you allowed people to buy marijuana the
use of marijuana went up isn't that what
you
I said that wherever you have softer
policies on drugs the consumption
increases what are you waiting for more
facts don't take no no don't take one
case to do an inference because it
depends in which way you will legalize
it this is a question which was asked
time and again from the audience and
also by our panelists who debate the
other position in which way you legalize
makes a huge difference as prices could
go up after legalization or down but
just one point vocally to you Robert
Bono which is your President Barack
Obama says that if you did have softer
policies on drugs you'll find that the
drug gangs actually just find other
illicit activities like human
trafficking and money laundering and
that kind of thing that they're likely
to go in that well of course they will I
mean organized crime is not going to go
away crud ganks are not going to go away
and after the legalization of alcohol
after prohibition organized crime didn't
go away they went into other kinds of
crimes including other kinds of draw
illegal drugs okay all right let's
listen more from the audience who's got
it stand please hi you asked us if we
wanted to live in countries full of drug
addicts however that does not take the
essential problem in South America is we
live in countries where 43 students are
killed where 75,000 people are killed by
or alerts so the DEA has been present in
our continent for quite a long time and
we have not seen the numbers positive
numbers from this war against drugs so
how do you suggest that we can tackle
this new war because if we cannot
legalize it what should we do
yep who's got the microphone yep there's
an aspect of in the debate which has
been neglected completely and that is
why why do why do people take drugs
isn't it just a cure pain okay we'll
take that as a comment who's got the
microphone yep
I've never seen a war a war being won
most people lose in wars and the war
that is being lost here is the
diction who cares about the person who
is addicted do you want your grandson
your grand grandson to be addicted no
not yours but mine so who makes decision
Thank You mr. president
would you like your grandchildren to be
drug addicts would you like them to go
into a supermarket to buy cookies laced
with cannabis for instance and the
question is and the question is how are
you going to regulate because I think
that the question of simply later rising
doesn't solve anything unless you have a
lot of other things and this is why I'm
talking about is it's not a magic thing
that just because you change a
legislation things are going to solve of
course not but let us be also what about
the other countries is not a question
for just one country it's a question for
the office countries also and what about
I will say in the United State this is a
domestic policy issue it has never been
possible only with President Obama in in
Cartagena was possible to have an
international discussion of the issue
and I say this is extremely unfair
because because you produce the money to
pay for that then we have to produce
which confuse about your points you
defend the idea that you need first
prevention then treatment then
regulation and then you have
legalization or do you think that
legalization will solve all or not at
all
you have to do the thing this is like
China if if you say that women you have
a free trade agreement but that you have
to prepare the country to use the
benefit of that that's just simply of
that it's not possible it's one word but
I'm trying to say is to make drugs
illicit okay has been working for so
many years and Ruth the result but let
Robert Boehner answer now because yeah
I know it's easy and many people blame
the United States for this problem but I
want to give you two data points that I
don't think you know one is that cocaine
use including crack in the United States
was at an all-time high in 1990 six
million regular users in the United
States that number today is 1.4 million
there has been and while how have we
done that it's first of all having laws
against traffickers and smugglers but
also drug education and drug treatment
for those that become addicted that's
the policy that's a drug control policy
this is true there was a substitution
from cocaine to heroin in the United
States and to address the question is
how large is a total drug market in the
US including marijuana soft drugs hard
drugs terrible drugs and intermediate
drugs we agree fully that our
government's got to concentrate more
resources in better design programs for
much stronger education of our kids
prevention and if that doesn't work
treatment of addiction I fully agree
with you dr. De Angelis that our
governments do not do enough how it can
they do more for instance having more
fiscal resources we have estimated for
the case of Chile and some similar
back-of-the-envelope calculation I think
would apply to Brazil to Asia or Africa
that if you legalize definitely not all
drugs but a significant chunk of those
drugs which which ones which ones would
you legalize the CBD LSD I go to Klaus
the motion is the world should legalize
drugs should legalize sequentially
gradually say cocaine heroin cocaine
Isis enrollee would be on the list of
legalize drugs but definitely not crack
and cocaine paste which are much more
strongly damaging excuse me yeah really
some thought you're arguing
but you've shifted to this no madam let
me go with regard to heroine in
Switzerland in crystalline with the
heroine they reduce the number of people
because they take care
the health problem if you are going to
legalize it's as important as knowing
you were president very quickly why
didn't you do this and if it's such a
great idea that's a good question
because I have several doubts on the
issue because I didn't was shook 100% -
I was invited for the first report on
the war on drugs and I didn't wanted to
sign it because I still have that if
that was the correct position so this is
not that much and I'll do little dad I
signed the second report the war on
drugs okay because I can convince either
one because I convinced that the war is
being defeated here in America we were
we were successful in Colombia but
because we are successful in Colombia
fighting without that we are producing
then then the narcos decided to wall
north
they didn't are going to be any more
with regard to the supply side by they
went to the demand side and this is what
you have now in Mexico therefore we are
paying the consequence as you see and
this is why I think that this has to be
an international agreement not a
domestic policy issue so everybody needs
to do it because it's a global problem
what I'm gonna do now he's gonna take
lots of brief brief brief comments from
the floor please gentleman in the green
I used to be a drug addict I'm not now
but I think the question is simple I
though it's the work best prepared for
more kids on drugs or more kids dev hmm
stark choice
I just want to reply to you mr. Lagos in
my country 45 students were killed and
that was because of the government I
don't want to see a government having
that business in their pocket so they
can cover all the true and not being
able to talk what is going inside the
government Mexico that's Mexico Mexico
junkies crackheads stoners really not
that I got the honor of serving with DEA
agents and the DEA Educational
Foundation I never never heard anything
under your surface talking about that
okay some of the points that were raised
there the chap who said I used to be a
drug addict and he's thinks it there's a
very stark choice between more kids on
drugs or more kids dead and I think by
that he's therefore in favor of some
kind of liberalisation so why don't you
pick that up doctor Reynaldo now injera
many many people who stopped using drugs
in America you have 20 Millions we're
former drug users no we have to be
hopeful that with the proper treatment
people stopping the drugs a President
Bush had alcohol problems for example
and he recovered from from from his
addiction all right let's put another
question there was a kind of gateway
question but may not have been
specifically this but just on the
legalization of cannabis which Klaus you
have been arguing for there is some
evidence isn't there that that kind of
becomes a gateway drug drug and that
young people think cannabis is all right
so maybe we'll go in for some cocaine
it's very much disputed it goes one way
or the other depending which study you
quote
what'd you what'd you say about it's
very much disputed there's a typical
issue where there is no black-and-white
evidence about the Gateway effects okay
let's just ask this Titan could that be
an exception made for marijuana Renaldo
because your do any magic
amongst these people I don't think so
the marijuana that you are talking about
is changing all the time even in America
15-20 years ago the content of cannabis
was 5% of THC that's the principal of
the economies today
this level is 10% and you have new
products reached 30 40 % therefore I
don't believe that cannabis is a soft
drugs anymore thank you okay
so you've heard our panel audience here
in Santiago the capital of Chile I would
like you to vote in our motion today the
world should legalize drugs if you are
for the motion press button number one
if you are against the motion press
button number two and if you're still
undecided you don't know press button
number three so let me just remind you
now before I give you the results of
this intelligence squared debate here in
Chile for the motion the world should
legalize drugs 59% of you were in favor
against 22% don't know 19 percent that's
how you voted in coming in and now this
is how your result you've voted for the
motion
52% against the motion 38 percent
undecided 10% so you lost seven
percentage points you gained if my
arithmetic is correct
[Applause]
16% well John and the don't know 10
percent but
you still managed to maintain your lead
so you have won the day congratulations
for the motion 52% commiserations but
also well done you pulled yourself up
from your bootstraps so thank you all
very much to our speakers in our
audience here in Santiago Chile and what
has been an extremely important debate
clearly it's something which divides
opinions here in the hall and across
societies and countries but it's a very
important debate a very important topic
that affects us all thank you to my
panel thank you to the audience thank
you to intelligence squared Chile for
making this possible from me Zainab
Badawi here in Santiago Chile at our
first BBC World News intelligence
squared debate in South America
hola bye
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]